Zoe first of all welcome to the St
Lucia's Club welcome to the junior girls
competition tell us about your initial
feelings playing here at this English
Club so obviously obvious is my second
time playing here and the first time
didn't go so well so I have absolutely
no expectations for this time but I'm
glad I started off the first round
nicely
and that was a great show of good
opening preparation I have to say but
also great middle game execution after
she allowed you uh to keep her King in
the center is that the moment where you
felt like you're taking over yeah I felt
like I was taking over well the first
one where I the first moment where I
really liked my position was when I
played E4 out of the opening and um E4
wasn't part of my preparation at that
point I was already kind of lost but I
was like okay I can isolated Pawn but
why the black's King is still stuck in
the center so I really like my position
here and then later once I played Queen
A3 I knew my position was really good
that was a key move yeah Queen 283 did
you feel like she missed that little
detail I feel like she might have messed
up because I missed it as well I mean up
until that point I was planning Rook E1
and then but after king f8 or something
the king is running to G7 and all I have
is an isolated Pawn Yeah but I realized
Queen A3 just stopping key f8 would be
really strong and then um this position
might I already have a really good
attack yeah yeah and I think uh the
advantage is pretty obvious on your side
she tried to defend but you kept pretty
much so Bishop takes C7 movement yes I
think I could have played Queen G3 like
I figured that out after I moved that
was probably a slightly more precise
yeah 23 this would be a really pretty
attack some Queen G6 Rook F6 stuff yeah
yeah I I think this is just resignation
time and then the rest of the game I was
like why didn't I just play Queen
still a great way to start your campaign
what are your Ambitions for this
tournament um this tournament I want to
not embarrass myself anyway
you definitely started that well guys
join uh the conversation anyway our
congratulations very nice the queen G3
moment when you miss queen G3 we've
actually caught that one too I'm
thinking yeah it would have been nice
but very good yeah congratulations on
finding the queen A3 move I think that
was a really very crucial move good job
and a very great start to the tournament
how do you feel now after you know
crossing the first first round and
managing to win well I already did
better than last time I think I started
with half a point out of seven so I'm
already doing a lot better than last
time which is really nice right well
then congratulations and good luck in
the rest of the tournament thank you
absolutely Zoe and uh